[Musique]
il est important que les sénateurs qui
vont bientôt délibérer et sur le budget
2023 de nos forces armées et sur la loi
de programmation militaire qui arrive
puissent se faire une idée venir au
contact de nos entreprises prendre la
mesure des technologies nouvelles qui se
mettent en oeuvre voir comment nous
pouvons aussi aider nos propres
entreprises qui sont exceptionnellement
qualifiés et qui apporte me semble-t-il
à notre défense sur mer des atouts
considérables
[Musique]
tout ce qu'on a pu entendre tous les
échanges qu'on a pu avoir d'abord nous
donne une idée de du climat aujourd'hui
on voit que tous les pays se réarme nous
vivons dans un monde excessivement
dangereux le domaine maritime est un
domaine de confrontation et donc puisque
jamais il est important que les
sénateurs puissent
s'informer au plus près
des choix qui vont être faits les
parlementaires ne travaillent que sur
dossier donc de temps à autres vont
venir sur le terrain et je crois qu'ils
ont tous apprécié d'abord la qualité de
l'accueil que nous avons reçu à la fois
de nos militaires et de nos industriels
et qu'ils ont retiré grand profit de
cette visite
[Musique]